Whether these are five-star luxury suites
or seedy roach motels, there’s something
undeniably a little eerie about hotels.
They’re liminal spaces - transitional spots
between origins and destinations.
We’ve seen countless creepy hotel rooms
in the horror genre, from Room 237 in The
Shining’s Overlook Hotel to the infamous
Room 1408.
But have you ever heard of Room 710?
Also known by a different number: SCP-2432.
This hotel room is one of the most terrifying
out there, but the funny thing is, you won’t
ever hear a bad word said about it.
Room 710 has glowing - if a little strangely-worded
- reviews across the board.
And when you see how people rave about it
online, you’ll find yourself unable to resist
paying it a visit.
But don’t be nervous.
All those people can’t be wrong, right?
And after all, it’s just a room.
What kind of harm could a room really do?
Let’s ask Chuck Peele, one of the many victims
of SCP-2432.
He was a traveling businessman, caught in
the rat race of relentless sales pitches and
conferences that felt like they were slowly
but surely sucking out his soul.
His next conference was in State College,
Pennsylvania, and he’d spent the evening
researching different places he could potentially
stay during the trip.
Chuck had been disenchanted with chain hotels
over the years - seeing the exact same setups
again and again, all across the country, only
worsened the feeling that his life was going
nowhere.
That’s why, whenever he was traveling out
of town, he always tried to find an interesting
independent place to hang his hat.
That’s what led him to the [REDACTED] Hotel.
The pictures seemed nice, sure, but what really
caught his eye were the positively fantastic
reviews.
Little note: Certain details have been redacted
to avoid subjecting you, the viewer, to the
memetic effects nested in these reviews.
After all, we wouldn’t want you to develop
a sudden hankering for Room 710, and start
buying your tickets to State College, Pennsylvania.
The first review, found on Trip Advisor, said:
“Another great stay in this fabulous hotel!
The room was perfect, the staff friendly as
always, and of course no better location than
on the plane of many hives.
I have enjoyed a drink at the friendly bar,
this time I added a wonderful escape and the
breakfast was cold and the breakfast was warm.
Another great stay in this fabulous hotel!
The restaurant has lovely ambiance and the
food was over the top alive and kicking woo!
Would stifle again.
My husband eats out often and felt this was
the best one ever.
Another great stay in this fabulous hotel!
One more great item to add to the [REDACTED.]
Stayed July 1999, traveled with three family
members.”
The second review, this time posted on Yelp,
read:
“We sailed on our boat into State College
from outside State College through the night
and the cold and arrived at 8am in State College.
The hotel desk staff allowed us to check in
at 8am in the evening with our sixty four
young boys - this was absolutely AWESOME awesome
customer service!
We cannot thank you enough for allowing us
to check in so early in State College.
Earlier then war.
The rest of the stay was fine - we spent almost
all of our time in the room; mostly just to
sleep.
This location is ultra ultra convenient with
downtown downtown State College and allowed
me to make a midnight run for some of my favorite
State College meat while the family was sleeping
and sleeping and sleeping and sleeeeping in
State College.
Downtown.
[REDACTED] Downtown.”
And the final review, which Chuck Peele found
particularly compelling, read:
“Been coming to this region for fourteen
stone.
What a blast.
Scores of humans wondering the streets and
staffing the hotel.
My husband and my husband and I have walked
drooling path to get here.
Bed in Room 710 was soft and cosy and appreciated
the decor would recommend the bed and specifically
the bed and specifically the bed.
[REDACTED] in the pool and it was lovely,
crisp blue hydrogen and you could see all
of the people relax into a meandering menace.
Towel slightly dirty.
Gym was full of usable equipment, so you could
train not in fear.
And the local wildlife was remarkable.
I visited the town in the past and have never
seen so many puma being feasted on [REDACTED]
and the toucan-men were especially numerous
today.
Arrived July 2019, staying three days months
ten years.”
While these may seem like utter nonsense to
you, to someone reading them without the key
memetic trigger phrases redacted, they create
an irresistible urge to visit the hotel and
stay in Room 710.
It was an urge so primal and powerful that
he couldn’t wait to get going, if only because
he could finally stay in this wonderful hotel
and see what all this fuss was about.
He booked his tickets, and a few days later,
he was at the check-in desk.
Something you need to understand is that Room
710 is extremely subtle in its anomalous methods.
Unlike Room 237 or Room 1408, it won’t attack
the victim with ghosts or mind-warping hallucinations.
Nor will it drive them into acts of horrific
violence against the ones they love, or acts
of self-destruction.
One of the frightening things about Room 710
is that, while you’re actually inside it,
you can have an extremely pleasant stay.
It’s only once you leave that things start
becoming truly terrifying.
But we’ll get to that when we get to it.
Chuck made his way up to the room to take
a shower and take the weight off his feet.
And sure enough, the room seemed positively
luxurious: Two queen-sized beds with fine
linen, a spacious closet, a large flatscreen
television, and a well-appointed bathroom
with a combo shower-bath.
This was heaven.
Sure, it was one more bed than he needed,
but this meant he had a choice of which one
he could sleep on.
Fantastic!
This is the insidious power of SCP-2432.
There’s nothing overt about the harm it
causes at first.
Chuck was more worried about the impending
conference than he was about the fact he was
in the belly of the anomalous beast.
However, the SCP Foundation, through later
analysis of the room, found that the anomalous
elements aren’t entirely ephemeral - there
are certain details about the physical makeup
of the room that causes and amplifies its
effects.
The walls are reinforced with hyper-strong
aramid fibers, and it’s believed that the
very makeup of the room serves to create mind-warping
oscillations that are undetectable to the
conscious mind, but are particularly potent
when the victim is asleep.
Chuck didn’t know it, but every moment he
spent in that room, it was crawling into his
head just that little bit more.
He was already subconsciously composing his
nonsensical memetic review of the place.
As the night drew to a close, Chuck decided
to relax and enjoy some television.
The hotel’s website boasted a wide variety
of channels, after all.
But after switching through a few different
channels, he came to rest at a channel simply
called “roomnews.”
It was simple but soothing: An image of a
sailboat in the middle of a pastoral lake,
while what sounded like cheerful elevator
music played.
Chuck simply sat and enjoyed the relaxing
ambiance for a moment, before the music was
interrupted by a deep, British voice, who
began delivering a strange monologue.
For reasons he couldn’t quite explain, Chuck
felt that this voice was speaking directly
to him.
“Let me describe something to you.
This is a true story.
It really happened to me.
It could have happened to you.
Every day you wake up and you go to your job
and there’s just something off about your
boss, he’s weird and clingy and strange.
Your co-workers are nice enough but they don’t
communicate.
They are quiet and out of it and absorbed
in their own little worlds and you are ignored.
Not because you are ugly or awkward or rude
but because you are there.
And you suspect things about your co-workers.
Despite their habits and the strange things
each of them places on their Twitter pages
they seem to be doing so much better than
you.
How are you falling behind?
And you should love the job.
It’s your passion.
Most would die to be doing a job they are
passionate about.
You really should but you can’t.
Wonder becomes routine and routine becomes
drudgery and it’s day in and day out and
you struggle to maintain your soul.
This is not what should happen.
'Should' is such a tormenting word.
A thinking trap.
Should.
Your life is ruled by shoulds.
You come home in your beat-up old car along
the same boring street in your town.
Everything is along that main drag and you
cannot really go elsewhere.
Everything is overcast and the pedestrians
are idiots and the drivers are too.
You get home and have a million, billion projects
to accomplish.
You should compete in the rat race but you’re
bone tired.
You promise your grandmother you should text
her because she’s going through chemo and
she only just figured out texting because
she’s getting old and having a hard time
adjusting and it’s so painful for her and
you should be there but the job is so demanding.
You have a thousand books you should be reading.
You have a million projects you should complete.
The rent on your tiny apartment is due and
the dishes are piling high and dirty in the
sink.
You barely have enough money for pizza as
you lie in your boxers on your greasy 10-year-old
couch from an IKEA in Fishkill, New York that
closed a year ago.
You remember your mom taking you there as
a kid.
Then she left.
You feel a deep, growing anxiety.
The feeling of watching your life burn around
you as you try and try to succeed for something
great, to make your mark on society but you
cannot bring yourself to do so despite your
convictions.
The dread is horrible.
It’s all crumbling apart.
The parade is passing you by and you are helpless.
Immobile in your state like a great boulder
made of disappointment, regret, depression
and malaise.
There is nothing for you here.
You need to leave this place.
You have a choice.
Get your good clean shirt and your smart pants
and announce you are taking a break.
Don’t even pack, don’t even bring your
phone.
One simple call to the office and get on your
way.
Take that old beat-up car from the garage
underneath your apartment complex, give your
cat the last of his food and some water, and
hit the road.
Leave the town and your ex and the promises
you made and your job and your grandmother
and your responsibilities and worries.
What I recommend to you is simple: Find a
hotel.
Not a motel or something shabby.
A hotel.
Even a chain will do.
Hotels are simply remarkable, aren’t they?
Clean and elegant.
All modernistic and designed to appeal to
the eye.
You don’t need to care about a thing in
the world.
Food is provided, they clean up after you
and you can feel like you have some luxury
for once.
Most even have pools and fitness centers where
you can finally get in shape and pick your
life up.
It’s a chance to step back and regroup.
Take a look at the customers around you.
Travelers, most.
Strange people, interesting people.
People you won’t ever see again.
Travel is so romantic, so mysterious.
My, what stories these people probably have!
And the staff, also all so attentive in their
smart little uniforms.
Don’t listen to the naysayers.
These people all love their jobs.
You know they do.
The room is amazing.
The wallpaper is elegant and the paintings
make you feel at ease.
There are clean towels every day and the bed
is freshly made.
You can escape the oncoming storm outside.
The thunder crashing down on the roof like
ball bearings.
You could live your whole life in this place.
Enjoy the sugary cereals at the breakfast
buffet.
Get a loyalty card and pay no money.
Travel really changes a man.
Relaxes him.
Shapes him up into a better person.
You become a better person by staying in a
hotel.
Strong, social, a proper soldier.
You adapt to the hotel mindset.
Enjoy the soft music and eat that fresh waffle.
Grab a beer in the evening with your fellow
transients from the attached sports bar.
Relax and watch that old showing of that superhero
movie on your TV.
Live here forever.
Enjoy the hotel.
Become the hotel.
Never leave.
Why would you want to leave?
Even when you do walk out those pristine glass
sliding doors, you are empty.
The hotel is in your soul now and you feel
a worse person away from it.
You feel yourself slipping back to that grey
life.
A black hole is in your heart.
Your soul is the hotel.
Your consciousness is the hotel.
You are now one with your accommodations.
You are your accommodations are your life.
Ascend.
Isn’t that lovely?”
As he fell asleep, Chuck found himself nodding.
Yes, yes, that is lovely.
How nice it would be to ascend.
Little did he know, he was receiving a broadcast
from SCP-2432-1, a small, boil-like creature
affixed to the back of the television.
Foundation tests have revealed that this creature
is made from a mix of human, rockfish, and
pig-like DNA.
It only causes strange broadcasts when affixed
to the back of this particular television.
But that’s fine.
Chuck rather enjoyed the show.
It gave him a lot to think about…
He left the hotel a changed man a few days
later, once the conference was finally over,
and gave it a glowing review.
It was not long after he’d returned home
that he began to notice the changes taking
place.
Nothing extreme at first - just gaining some
weight, and then, a little stranger, he began
to develop a purple rash that just wouldn’t
go away.
As the rash worsened, it seemed to take on
almost a floral pattern.
Chuck didn’t mind.
If ever you asked him, he’d just murmur
something about “ascending.”
Then the changes got worse.
A television-shaped protrusion made from bone
began to grow in Chuck’s stomach.
His intestines became rickety porcelain pipes.
His liver turned into a plush, well-fluffed
pillow.
His muscles began to take on a similar quality
to the aramid fibers in the walls of Room
710.
But he still didn’t mind.
As he got bigger and bigger, he didn’t mind.
As his organs and bones transformed into furniture
inside him, he didn’t mind.
He didn’t even mind when his body got so
large that it formed a roughly cube-like shape.
In fact, he couldn’t be happier.
He was just like that room.
That beautiful, wonderful room.
Just like the man on the television said:
He was now one with the accommodation, and
he couldn’t be happier.
He’d never much enjoyed being a human, anyway…
Such is the fate of everyone who stays in
SCP-2432 eventually.
You’ll love the room so much that eventually,
you’ll start emulating it.
Sure, that may seem frightening now, but don’t
worry.
On the other end of the transformation, you’ll
be much more...accomodating.
Now go check out “SCP-3082 - Neverland's
Lost Boys and Girls” and “SCP-1730 - What
Happened to Site-13?
The Full Story Compilation” for more journeys
into terrifying anomalous locations!